you apparently panicked when you were
hired for Archer
is that true when they hired you for
Archer just because a job you panicked
well I didn't read the script
um notoriously underprepared know
everything and then when I found out it
was a spy I panicked because I thought I
would have to do British you have to do
a British accent yeah cuz all spies are
British yeah and you don't have a strong
British accent well I have a little I
can do a little bit let's hear it hello
how are you
cup of tea please thank you thank you
sir stop you can't just say cup of tea
cup of tea that's what I did when I was
in Britain yeah and they kept giving me
- yeah proper tea cup of tea cup yeah
Archer has a catchphrase danger zone and
that thing has pot on fans love danger
zone you get that a lot when you walk
around in the world people shouting
danger zone I do sometimes people will
shout it out out of their cars and it's
it's complicated because not a lot of
people know what I look like you know
right so when a kid like shouts out
danger zone out of a car and no one
knows it's me it can be people can read
the situation confused as an actual
danger zone
in the West Village in New York like if
I'm walking around some danger zone and
then everybody is like what now guys
it's just me yeah - catchphrase from
you